schule in zeiten von corona darüber
spreche ich mit hans peter meidinger
präsident des deutschen lehrerverbandes
ehemaliger schönen guten abend die erste
frage an sie die schule geht jetzt
wieder los in einigen bundesländern
welches bauchgefühl haben sie
grundsätzlich wenn sie daran denken dass
millionen schüler jetzt wieder im
klassenzimmer sitzen in den pausenräumen
sind auf dem hof proben rennen was
glauben sie
also grundsätzlich wünschen wir uns
natürlich alle also das geld für die
lehre auch im besonderen maße wieder
mehr normalität im unterricht und dass
wir unsere schüler alle wieder im
unterricht auch die schulen können wir
gesehen dass per fernunterricht gar
nicht so gleichwertig ist
auf der anderen seite haben wir eine
riesige herausforderung was den
gesundheitsschutz anbelangt und da muss
man natürlich sehen wenn die
abstandsregelung fällt in den
klassenzimmern unter die wird ja auch
jetzt fallen sowohl in mecklenburg
vorpommern wie in den anderen und
ausländern die starken was man dann da
dagegen setzen kann und da hatte ich
grundsätzlich auch die diskussion über
die masken pflicht für durchaus geboten
das hat nrw heute beschlossen masken
pflicht im unterricht erzählen sie
erklären sie mir warum sie das für
sinnvoll halten
also die bisherigen ersatzmaßnahmen für
dieses abstandsgebot in klassen sind ja
die isolierung von lerngruppen hat man
ja auch im beitrag gesehen
beziehungsweise lüftungskonzept reihen
testungen von lehrern und da muss man
sagen dann stoßen wir an grenzen also
ich sage mal nicht im nationalen
oberstufe da kann man nicht isolieren
die sind in einem kurssystem mit der
rüstung klappt es in vielen schulen auch
nicht weil die fenster sich nicht öffnen
lassen
und dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch eben
die massen pflicht ich bin was lehrer
selber natürlich nicht begeistert neben
sg im unterricht tragen zu müssen
aber ich glaube es ist ein balanceakt
die man die alternative wäre verstärkt
das infektionsgeschehen und eventuell
wieder schulschließungen und das will
keiner deswegen glaube ich müssen wir
mit bestimmten einschränkungen leben
jetzt habe ich gerade gesagt nrw hat das
bereits beschlossenen mecklenburg
vorpommern gilt das zum beispiel nicht
es gibt also wieder so eine art
flickenteppich in allen bundesländern
warum warum gibt es da keine einigkeit
was glauben sie ja gut also ich glaube
die megawatt vortragen wird jetzt haben
wir haben ein bisschen weniger
infektionen der zeit und bei uns ist ein
stück nicht so groß wie in ordnung ist
vor allem das ist natürlich richtig auf
der anderen seite je früher und die
konsequente machen auf solchen regine
schütt selbst desto größer ist auch die
sicherheit dass schule dann nicht
beeinflusst ist von infektionen
beziehungsweise man ein
infektionsgeschehen schnell in den griff
bekommt deswegen würde ich mir dort
tatsächlich auch mehr einheitlichkeit
wünschen wir wissen zum beispiel nicht
was jetzt die reiserückkehrer kommen oft
aus risikogebieten die heimat urlaub
gemacht haben etwa in der türkei oder in
russland was die jetzt an
infektionsgeschehen in die schulen
hineintragen